hello and welcome to this video this is
the recap for Round four of the London
chess classics so what did we have in
this round five games of course and it
was a was an interesting round and I
have to say that it's a bit tricky to
cover all of it because yeah the games
were yeah all somewhat interesting and
I'm going to start with them in
comparison least interesting game this
is Gil your own yarn we got an English
opening giving us going for for this and
it goes for this line with a form and
this is an interesting choice usually
leading to a longer yeah maneuvering
battle um however there's one
interesting feature that's position
we're going to see that yeah this kind
of thing it's something that is very
interesting white now has the bishop
pair where we see that is the bishop on
c1 and a bishop 1g2 and you would assume
that white wants to open the position to
make this a bishop pair more effective
right at the moment this bishop for
example it's looking at this pawn it
doesn't make a very very powerful
impression the thing is white does not
want to open the position quite the
opposite he wants to keep the position
closed for the moment because he is
lagging in development he wants to keep
it closed and opened the position later
on his own terms what black wants to do
is he wants to use his development
advantage it would be bad for black to
play something let's say like d6 and his
position after which white happily
continues with something like this and
later maybe like castles f4 and so on
slowly trying to expand and gain space
black wants to play in a somewhat in a
fast fashion he wants to open the
position quickly
and this starts with C 6c 65 quickly try
to use the development advantage
interestingly enough and give replays in
the same way with black hair he had a
funny game one with black against em
shaqeeya mamedyarov only in 2014 I think
that was qatar qatar masters or
something like that one of those strong
open tournaments and my jar of played a
92 in that game and then also d5 was
played and give me one a very nice game
and a good attacking style um here you
played 9003 with wide so he plays it
with both colors gand Aronian goes t5
that was the idea and white has to do
this and now we see a black has castle
already it's got the rukon yet and he's
got very clear development knight c6
Bishop f5 Quincy to was played and now
Aronian goes Quincy 7 directly attacking
this somewhat weak porn he also could
have just developed but why not attack
the pawn um yeah white can try to cover
it but those moves don't look very good
yeah I mean something like this
ultimately you have to reckon with ideas
like this not not right away but it is
in the position and black still can just
develop if he likes this should be too
looks a little bit more interesting at
first but Bishop f5 already has the
first concrete threat of night before so
black should be ok as well give me just
gave away the pawn ok here we go yeah
what does white hair for the pawn he is
um yeah catching up in development and
in fact now as he has canceled now add
now it is his move he probably has a
slightly better development even also
gained a tempo on that night so here
white has an interesting choice i can go
Bishop b2 as ghee we did or looky one
rookie one is a little bit more
ambitious and something like this is
that
the line given by the engine their white
is a porn down but definitely has some
kind of compensation one idea is for
example that this squares rather weak
this can come here interesting but what
is that for the moment foodporn down
yeah give you plenty is a more of a safe
player so he decides to get the porn
back but this allows black to catch up
in development here in 96 and I think
here black has some probably equalized
that night comes back to be six bishops
is 17 and again blackest getting his
father piece into the play why does got
the bishop pair but white also has got
weaknesses too yeah to look after and um
and it is a very dry and position this
is interesting aronia also could have
chicken here just like that and just be
okay it's a much simpler way into play
but this is probably working there's
nothing great for wide available for
example here white cheeks on b7 there's
rupee aid and something like this is
just not very much White has this porn
here but black always has ideas like
bishop h3y end yeah that's that's okay
for black give me play Bishop e7 okay
one yeah it's quite funny if you're if
you ask the computer here it gives Ruby
one as as a good good try Bishop a to
the idea said rook be to check it
doesn't help so the engine gives Luke a
one and sorry this bill should be seven
this is why what's going to show you
should be seven
be one gypsy aid and stockfish gives
white 0.7 it's funnier so the engine has
a very high evaluation of the bishop
pair of course this is just a dead ROI I
mean I'm a huge bishop pair fan but
three again three on one side of the
board where the non bishop pair side has
zero weaknesses it's just an instant
draw yeah so funny compute the
evaluation okay okay one and now be five
is an important move move that porn out
of the scope of the bishop and threatens
before trying to fix a weakness there so
why it has to yeah attend to that with a
three tier we can continue a little bit
here that trade it down to a complete
draw yeah so we hadn't probably some
people interesting opening bats out
there with c65 being somewhat
counterintuitive maybe to some to some
players but it is really the right way
to play if you play in a slow way with
d6 and b6 or whatnot then white is
building up happily with this bishop
pair in the case of where the side with
the Knights wants to accelerate the play
this is really the term that describes
the best i think he wants to make it
make it fast make it tactical in a way
that the Knights can do something real
quickly before the bishop pair gets ya
set up properly to them to use his
powers okay so let's go now to Greece
shock versus mdl and this is one of
those games where you know that there
will be turn trouble and you have a very
good guess with the opening and yeah and
it is an idol of ya MV outlays the night
of reshop usually place that opens the
salient so we've got the night off and
glee show goes for the old main line
Bishop g5 yeah Bishop g5 was all the
rage in the 1960s 70s maybe also in the
80s and then subsequently got replaced
by Bishop e3 at the main move but yeah
nowadays still Bishop g5 is the sharpest
move I guess so e 6 + f4 h6 retreats and
Bishop Queen to be six dead aslam am a
modified version of the poisoned pawn
yeah the poisoned pawn as Fisher plated
was Queen B 6 on mu 7 without age six
and Bishop age form inserted there are a
couple of nuances there between the two
versions I have to say that I'm not a
very knowledgeable person in practice
opening I am I play tonight often factor
for for a couple of years when i started
with chess which is kind of crazy but it
was one of the first openings that i
learned because i started out with
vicious games and he always played the
night off um but back then i unlearn to
Bishop e7 and not be t7s defenses and
it's like 25 years ago um so I'm kind of
important I'm not an expert um Grisha
quent a 3 that's an interesting choice
he covers the pawn why why is that
covering the porn because queen bee 294
leaves the black queen without any
squares it's funny way to cover the pawn
but it happens quite often in in many
openings at a three by taking away the
a3 square is covering this this pawn um
yeah Queen d2 is the main move this is
what I what I saw in them in the
database but I don't make a theoretical
serving out of it yeah but should be
seven Bishop f2 so this is an
interesting point the bishop from age 4
can drop back to have to so the black
queen feels uncomfortable and retreats
to c7
queena 3 p-5 g4 so we've got a very nice
sharp Sicilian position now it's six
castles long so this is one of those
nowadays relatively rare cases where we
will see opposite sides castling very
likely okay Black has not cancelled yet
but it's a likely that this is going to
happen it's interesting to note that
this is innocent looking north age six
has far-reaching consequences as now we
can already see a further short castles
runs directly into g45 okay um Bishop d7
very logical and age for pushing on the
King side ya hear mvl opted for d5 a
direct counter play in the center not
castling yet interesting choice um we
shook now went 85 I think this is
probably best he could have taken but
after night XD form Bishop before Knight
takes d5 think black is good yeah
there's this big threat and why doesn't
have any particularly great option you
have something like Bishop g2 for
example black and also just cancel and
nothing bad seems to happen we have to
note that leg also has a half open sea
fan so it's not that wide can just like
blehh g5 and and play for checkmate um
II five I think it's a better choice 94
and teams takes Queen c3 okay if white
takes my gvoice going to be embarrassing
so he had to move the Queen on the side
and now rook c8 covering the Queen on c7
and lining up piling up on the C file
yeah it looks like a very as a sharp
position but it feels at least their
first glance pretty balanced look h3
getting out of that diagonal finally
yeah adhere white has to trade f5 yeah
it's still a pretty sharp position and
we have the Queen's traded but there are
many things going on Black has display
on them on the C file and against the
king but wyd has said space advantage on
the Kings side and already has advanced
to have five okay castles on move 11 so
Black has delayed that to a moment where
it feels reasonably safe um yeah right
now can take only six but it doesn't net
that much note that all of a sudden this
look is active yeah and I mean why can
absolutely not take SC two XL yeah so
what should you do we shook went for
Bishop you won we are removing that
Bishop on their file and also having a
look at that night so that something
like f6 gets to be a more interesting
tactic Bishop d5 and now g5 trying to go
f6 very very sharp position so what
happens now if black takes f6 that was
the point yeah now this is an overload
of the bishop takes and takes yeah now
where should the bishop go if you go
like here then white will just take and
the open age file is super dangerous no
black hand check give it a check here
but okay so this is possible and that
didn't didn't help a lot yeah
it can be really ugly quickly and this
for example is going to be made it's a
very very tough position to play um mvl
went here ya go for the C 2 square and
pawn bishop before yeah why just had to
get rid of this and now played f6 um
instead he also could have taken on age
6 but that doesn't help that much as
black can take here and the White Knight
cannot take due to see to being under
such heavy pressure very sharp position
but it seems to be balanced f6 instead
is better and now interesting choice
king age 7 and c 3 i'm joking and now
took the g file it was the idea behind
King age 7 to take on f6 and then you
said you said open file yeah that's a
pawn but ok i'll pawn this is such a
dynamic position that the pawn is not so
important um here black has a couple of
ideas they're connected to the e porn
and the move rock g2 right now plate 9
p-5 note that greece sugars in this
typical time trouble already and 95 i
think is a good choice because it leads
to what happens in the game pretty much
yeah almost bad force and I think white
can be okay with them with the
development of the game he has got no
time at the position is very tricky um
ok this is what happened attacking that
Bishop Bishop he has the only move that
makes any sense rook b6 take stakes and
now we see that this night is hanging
and doesn't have that many squares 94
was playing in the game this was the
sharp alternative but like is just in
time with rook g2 to counter-attack and
here
the likely result is a draw and an
interesting point is that deform is not
leading to anything because of the
capture check so this was played and now
after takes and takes rook g two blacks
counterplay is sufficient for a draw at
the end there we got that wrong yeah
note that the time is not quite ok yeah
the relay time is a little [ __ ]
annotating what Grisha wasn't an trouble
but it wasn't him check it wasn't enough
to to yeah to alter the result of the
game he had no time but it was easy
enough let's say that he could manage
even with just a couple of seconds on
the clock and interesting Sicilian
battle with them a little bit more let's
say under the surface then I have now
shown in the video but I want to make
sure that I don't get he has such
epically long videos this time I want to
get a good overview so that you have an
idea what happened in the games but I
don't want to analyze all the games in
such detail that we got like 90 minute
videos I mean I look at the statistics
and they're just like two or three
percent of the people watched the whole
night you need videos so I think a good
good compromises is in order showing the
most important things but don't make it
don't make it too long ok and let's go
for the next game and this is 2 pi love
caruana that is some an important game
every game is important in this event we
have to be honest there but it's to
Paolo is edit delete in the overall
grandchester before the event but had an
absolutely rotten start
he needs a win badly to get back into
the race and of course kawana up to now
only has played draws and it wouldn't
would be be quite nice so let's see what
happened hmm okay it got interesting I
have to admit it got interesting and
let's see what happened d3 Bishop c5 c3
ok have shown it a bit a couple of times
already went white cannot win a banya
due to that tactic so C 3 and cancels
again why cannot take upon so Morton to
know and d5 leads to excellent gambit
play for black yes sir in in very good
shape with this development and white
has to be cautious to not getting into
big trouble here ok night BTW to was
played to paula was not cancelling note
that he's delaying this move and this
leads to interesting plain 97 kawana
going over to g6 very good regrouping
the night on g6 has some ideas in
regards to that and sometimes that can
place the sex and deform and just back
to be 6 yeah to part of now to Kali 5
and played Queenie to UM could have
taken only five well it leads to
interesting plane like has a a couple of
ideas one idea that the engine is giving
is the move queen to d6 just attacking
this night and asking how wide is going
to handle this now if you go back then
96 is a simple recipe yeah why is that a
move or why is just canceling not good
Black has some compensation one idea is
that right here 'if I've sorry bishop h3
is an interesting choice note that this
bishop
is very strong if white no tix is going
to assign check blues right away this is
not going to end well and so here he has
to be five and this might might lead to
a draw just about a white but it's a
rather dangerous game yeah tupelov just
played Queenie true yeah developing or
putting out the Queen and after 96 now
face an important choice night f4 is a
really annoying move and what are you
doing now against it um he decided on a
on a very risky plan strategically risk
him he played a g3 why said risky ok if
you play g3 how are you going to cast on
short as Oasis a tree pointing ok you
can argue let's play H for that but this
is a pretty substantial weakening of the
Kings side so it's a risky decision with
this on top i love is basically saying
i'm going to ya keep my king in the
center for a while or cancel long and
this is in fact what he did and he went
for ya let's put this on the board went
for non canceling it's a very rare
occurrence in the ruler pesum and in
this particular position on I think
everything points to black being in very
good shape but it's not so easy to prove
kawana now place the most normal moves
bishop e6 and goes b5 to open up the
position or trying to open up the
if Y it now takes on b5 night XD form is
excellent for black the night is very
strong end we already see ideas of
potential sacrifice in C 1 C 3 so what
cannot take and he went c4 and this is a
move that is enormously committal yeah
with c4 okay black played before can put
down on the board with this move you're
essentially killing your own piece down
d3 that looks like a very stupid piece
now and you basically commit yourself to
find compensation for the bad bishop and
also the very weak square on deform
first glances that kawana is clearly
better because of that but things are
not that straightforward I think he
really should be better but it's
difficult to prove yeah this was played
and this is the only reason why why its
position is playable in the first place
that this night is pretty strong 97-91
the idea of 91 is that white maybe wants
to use the f porn in the further cause
of the game yeah 91 here I think I wanna
made a mistake and but I think it's
pretty clear that this was a mistake now
it's not just my exclusive opinion he
went c6 what black um wants to do
ideally is of course put a knight on d4
somehow and get rid of the D 59 so you
want to play c6 under the most favorable
circumstances c6 so that the night has
to go back and then somehow we route so
that a Black Knight might come to deform
it's very difficult to
English it's really difficult to do and
looked at a couple of lines but they are
not entirely conclusive for example
something like a four if we start with a
492 and then something like rugby a try
to maybe play rugby seven and then c6 I
know it's slow but i just want to show
the idea then white goes that form and
this is not clear at all white hands f4
f5 after c6 you can drop back and this
is not not clear at all that black is in
good shape when the position is
interesting and and then very
double-edged but it doesn't look like
refutation of white set up and it really
feels like there should be something 26
is an interesting trial immediately
going 46 but after Bishop c2 there is
this idea and yeah black probably has to
take on d5 now and there are not many
alternatives yeah takes on 25 and now
white um has to recapture see pawn takes
pawn takes rook takes I think he takes
looks like the most logical move all of
a sudden a bishop get strong the Kia
black has nothing to fear particularly
kanokon right c5 next for example at
yesterday and upon but still the
position doesn't feel completely
conclusive to me some of those lines
forever he probably should have played
SC 6 is even leading to abide advantage
97 here and now to part of captured this
kind of double porn is not necessarily a
weakness in all cases it looks weak the
pure structure looks weak but often you
can compensate by control of squares so
d4 for example is an important square
that is controlled by the double porn
and also defies very reliably controlled
it's difficult to ever for Black team
organizes p
you would absolutely love to get a
knight on d4 but how how exactly now
with the pony 6 this is not a possible
route and moving the Queen playing c5
then I'd be eight the 96th and 94 this
is very slow and come on and never
manager something like that age warm and
Bishop back in 93 now this night is
activated and he goes for for the trade
and white is also quicker on the D file
and we see that this night isn't
terribly bad peace now it is on g6 it
doesn't attack anything and looks at
mostly controlled squares if we could
magically and it would really require
magic transfer to d4 then black would be
in great shape or even see five if we
are a little bit more modest but it's
difficult to accomplish it's really
difficult to do now there's the pressure
on the D file and koala decides to to
capture here we go this is why the
bishop is still not such a bad piece and
attack something imported Quincy five
rookie to covering the f2 pawn you had
this trait nothing that black did with
the smile on his face I guess as the
disappearance of that c4 porn meet said
this Bishop will get strong check yeah
or here yeah and here it's pretty clear
that around here to paula has excellent
winning chances his bishop is so much
better than blacks night is got four
against three on the King side which is
helping with the potential
Tech and all in all many end games will
be winning for what for example if you
trade Queens you can be pretty sure that
you will win this it's however not
something you can force yeah no Queen
trade of course again no Queen trade
yeah just to show if black is training
Queens why there's a lot better he has
some some straightforward ideas rooks
these six to attack that pawn you can
bring the King up and black is also
somewhat helpless he's always tied to
that e-cigs born so we kept the Queen on
the board and we have a interesting
moment here rook c8 have played by
Caruana he's covering them the c5 pawn
yeah and now you can ask what about
Bishop a 6 isn't that isn't that a move
here it is a move but it seems to be
that after after that Kara wanna is
scanning enough counter play i am not
one hundred percent sure though I have
to admit because I had limited time in
the analysis and I wouldn't completely
rule out that there is something for
white still but we have a look and you
will see why I'm unsure Bishop a6 Queen
SF that was the point like it's giving
away the look check for this
counter-attack twin takes a to check
King back to the one and now see form
it's amazing kawana has sacrificed a
full look at the moment but he's got a
huge count to play with those two pawns
and the Queen yeah how does that
continued look the two was played by two
part of that's the best move if you go
to droop deform then b3 is already
rather dangerous and requires why to
give back his rook there's no way around
it and just kind of thing in check ja is
a straight sorry is a straight forward
draw
is absolutely no doubt that black wall
manager perpetual him and he played this
this is the tougher tough sensuous chick
and here we go it seems that this is
this is a draw I mean I looked a little
bit and looked at it a little bit with
with stock fish and it ultimately always
some gave drawers but it's not so easy
the computer is not just giving that 000
straight away so that you are sure but
rather give zweiten some slight
advantage but if you go deeper and
deeper and help a little bit with some
forcing lines then you'll see that it
will jump back to two drawers to
Perpetual's nevertheless yeah Queen f8
plate is giving up the roof but there is
no real alternative to to that if white
tries to keep this piece there is b3
coming and this also doesn't help yeah
this is a this is an interesting try big
Stig's check out here white only has a
check perpetual himself yeah Queenie
evade is the relatively toughest took
white has to take check and now check on
b2 and the engines actually give a
different check they give Quincy three
as a little bit more precise and I think
it's still at all be honest check this
is very forced yeah it's the only way
for whites you're trying to escape in
the first place and now there is the
move age 5 and this is the the big point
something that kawana needs to have seen
somewhat somewhat beforehand now the
king is strapped and we threaten the
perpetual only way for white to avoid it
for the moment is g4 check and now a
queen f1 was so also an alternative but
koala takes and I think it is a draw
still check even though
the game's not over yet Czech Czech like
has a ton of checks of course you could
chat analyze this a little bit and look
at alternatives but it's very tricky to
do whatever you know this is essentially
a queen at game be three yeah it looks
slow but the bee pollen is dangerous and
this Bishop is kind of kind of out of
the picture this is the best tribe check
and now white city as a pawn up and you
will get the people I just want to look
at one particular situation check check
so check what to this with whites you're
having a pawn check but with the open
wide King position they're still check
very decent drawing chances here after
26 it's a definite perpetual um some
other move which is great analysis i
know but some other move Queen c5 check
Queen g5 check they would have at least
continued the game very likely it's it's
a draw still but it's not a draw that is
an immediately confirmed by by an engine
that there's no direct perpetual which
happens after Queen here so we had to
have to check out and let's say continue
here but it's difficult for white to
make any progress the computer also is
not so reliable here because it always
see a series of checks for white which
makes the whole line longer longer
longer and longer and it doesn't really
recognize that white is not able to make
any progress with an open King um in the
game Queen g6 was played check check
check this was a direct-drive it's no
way to avoid it and something like this
there's a check here and this is his
typical Jack kind of check pursued by
the king by the Queen always lining up
against white screen so white can never
done go ahead and now this so at the end
of draw a tough fighting game that so
first nakamura being a sorry
corona that's the next game hey Kara
wanna being a comfortable and then to
pile of quite a big advantage but then
there was this this situation with
Bishop basics of course you can argue if
we if we go back again of course you can
argue that two part of could have played
something different here and just keep
his advantage I mean he has many moves
that he can play that a better for why
that's a 5 h five or something like that
just a normal move but it's of course
very tempting to grab the rook and he
decided to go for it because he probably
did not see a direct draw probably
correctly I mean there is no direct draw
but it seems that maybe h5 was that was
a better choice at the end to keep more
pressure on and very tough game okay so
that means to power off stays on minus
two and peruana one fifty percent after
having played four drawers ok now can do
is actually not the next game it's a car
it's cards and Micky Adams so let's put
that one up so let's see if the drawing
streak for one of those players is going
to end world champion magnus cars and
it's played three drawers he's gotten
close to 22 wins but it hasn't
materialized yet and Adams being mr.
solid let's say he played three drawers
and was wasn't in any danger any of
those games very good very good
performance so Carlton goes for Knight
f3 g3 setup which is some yeah actually
what I was this train I am his sir his
coach I would recommend him to do stuff
like that and skip the onee for openings
but ok we'll see if this was any better
than then then the Berlin send and
exactly okay he plays on this kind of
ratty style opening this is a position
that easily could happen in one of my
games as I play this kind of opening
with white and I add me admit that it
doesn't look very exciting at first but
what it usually does is it doesn't
simplify already on it keeps most pieces
on the board and there are no clear
lines that black and play that would
kill the game outright as it sometimes
happens in and let's say e4 e5 openings
and so concentrated here we captured a
funny little tactic you should always be
aware of is this thing tactic is a
strong word yet it's a blonde I
absolutely never never fall for that one
so it takes nine to three castles 83 and
e4 yeah that is the whole idea of whites
set up there with c4 and the capture on
d5 the idea is not that cheaper with
Queen a for the idea said this position
is in fact rather interesting to play
and quite often if black decides to
capture white has a form that was wrong
a four against three three pawn majority
on the King side and this often is them
yeah this often leads to interesting
plain white light moves the Queen away
Bishop our night away in that f4 this is
the general idea getting all those pawns
into motion and this very often leads to
interesting attacking play even on the
Kings side I think this is one reason
why Adams never takes only for in this
game he just keeps the tension and asks
what if he has any useful moves without
the capture yeah cousin immediately
answers that question and goes for the
capture on d5 rookie one
and deform yeah is this a position where
white has an advantage hmm probably not
so much but white is it a little bit
easier to play as it seems that he's got
more play against d5 then black has
against d4 we have that typical REM
structure again in the center something
that we already had in Carlin's game
against caruana i think in round two he
however the pizza place with the
distribution is entirely different yeah
especially there are more pieces on the
board in the first place so 97 getting
that back into the game a 3d form
getting a little bit of space yeah here
Adams goes for the most a 60 which
doesn't feel so essential because I mean
I don't think that'd be five is a big
threat and it's not it's not so clear
that you need to make her then G to make
that move and it gives white a little
idea i am putting the night here and on
c5 it makes some pressure against b7 um
here now black has to be I think quite
precise if he is making one or two more
um let's say yeah less than optimal
moves then you can get into trouble on
the queenside you played a 5 directly
going at those pawns 95 ticks ticks and
rugby aids to cover that porn queen a
form very logical white tries to maybe
oops I am drawing like a madman hear
something like night XP 7 can get into
the picture now with that pressure on on
c6 yeah now um Adam skills form a pretty
much forced operation he takes it and
place Queen f6 this is a double attack
looking at the pawn and then and the
bishop at first you think that this is
just just okay for black but if you look
at this little bit deeper queen bee
three you see that there's oasis what am
I doing here that 97 idea yeah that
wasn't possible earlier because the
bishop was hanging but now it is a
threat so Adams is covering it Bishop g4
now so what's strange-looking move but
it has a very clear idea again Knight to
d7 yeah and he just took the pot you
just took the pawn this is ultimately an
exchange sacrifice check I'm sorry Gardy
not check a check on the Queen yeah 27
I'm good Quincy for and now white hands
97 that is what I was trying to say this
is the mentioned exchange sacrifice that
black hat plant now the be a drug Hanks
and d6 Bishop hangs so black has to give
up the exchange what does he have he's
got one paw at the moment and we'll get
rid of that beep 1 and this is happening
I want to go to a certain position he's
shuffling the night until you found this
setup and this is something that is very
interesting to look at from a human
perspective and also from the
perspective of the computer yeah it
doesn't matter what engine you look this
position
which engine you use to check this
position they all give white a very
substantial advantage something that is
close to a win like 1.3 1.4 however for
a human player it is pretty clear that
this position must be very very very
very close to a draw why is that um if
you check this the set up you see that
those three pieces they are perfectly
organized white um cannot attack one of
them porn protects Bishop Bishop
protects night there is no one
instability there they all form one
cluster let's say one unit the second
unit is the kingside the king and the
three pounds and f7 as the weakness that
is a tech there by bishop and rook is
protected by the night on d6 so how is
right ever going to improve from here
you can try to invade with the king this
is however difficult as you see that the
bishop is taking away squares and the
night as well and this means there's
almost a barrier here in the center as
long as black as of moving those pieces
White's king is not going to enter so
what is he supposed to do you can push
the Kings side forward and this will see
that cars will do that but ultimately
that also shouldn't help some shelling
on came up check yeah g5 that he has won
a particular idea in mind that we would
see in the game I'm going for some sort
of f5 it's um it's even less promising I
mean right away it's probably not doing
anything but just in general like will
always be able to go here and go to f6
and then this pawn is basically
so something was g5 is the relatively
best choice and Johnson had an idea
which at least made it somewhat
interesting check this is what he did
sacrificing this bishop the idea is that
arm to this and rook c6 this pawn is not
going to be yeah cannot be saved Bishop
deform had to be played there's also
this red so and here yeah when I looked
at this just very briefly during a live
show that ahead on Monday I was thinking
that white has winning chances the pawns
look dangerous but um it seems that
there is not much going on check sorry
that was a bit bit too quick and check
him and this is the key idea double
attacking this g6 fails to night h6
check and something like this is also
not eating too much this is again double
attacked as I after a couple of shakes
mg 698 six now is very nice it will win
that porn check yet here they agreed to
a draw I was actually slightly surprised
at carleton didn't continue for a couple
of moves it is of course a draw but well
we have seen weirder things happen okay
if you by the way if you want to look at
this end game a little bit look against
the lone Knight I've made a video on
that in my basic end game series it's
about one year old you can look at the
playlist where you have rook against
bishop and rook against night some
examples of the play the reason why this
is a straight draw is that a king and
night are close to one another
they're only chances where the look can
sometimes win against the long night is
when it is at the edge of the board and
there are some kind of the king at night
are somewhat torn apart they're kind of
double it takes possible and they can be
there can be skewers things like that
and here with everything coordinated
nothing should happen ok so again a draw
if I'm the two players and yeah tough
for cards I mean he had some good good
position than chances but couldn't get a
win in he seems more stable than in the
recent events but doesn't get to the
point where he wins the game maybe maybe
next round ok so let's go for the final
game after 4 drawers we look at this one
Nakamura honored it's sometimes
interesting to check the personal scores
of players against one another there are
some weird things yeah even players that
of approximately equal strength then
sometimes have huge scores against one
another I mean famously Nakamura has
lost like 10 or 11 games two cars and
never won a single one and yeah but look
at Nakamura and Arlen they have almost
identical ratings and the camera wins
almost he wins escapes against our
Lantern yeah a lot of them had to yo
nila has lost one yeah I think he's plus
six or plus seven against fishy ok so we
have a Catalan an opening with Quincy
too that's a very rare line to institute
that early move and usually they play on
casualty which is the absolute main line
of the Catalan with black capturing
Quincy to is an interesting sideline
that I also have played myself a little
bit here and there as a surprise one
idea of the line is that the usual
procedure of taking one c4
not now is in fact not so precise both
queen takes e4 and night BTW to they
promised wide some advantage one idea of
an IBD to us by the way that the move b5
is not working at all due to what was it
it's a full ride an a4 c6 and TX takes
and 95 this is a one tactical point said
to recollect that age 6 now there's
there's a meeting thread on age seven so
95 is not possible to save the rook
black has to go age six and then aged
four is a funny funny point and black is
basically losing funny to the line I had
this on the board and in blitz games
okay c5 that is the main move and
something that wish she had played
before only sorry only this year we're
going to follow that game Castle
mistakes I takes Queen B 6 attacking the
knight routier 196 and takes takes this
position um they had on a lot already
had on the board um against aronia and
funny enough in the Stavanger tournament
so that was the the first lack of the
this grandchester way i'm on and
ultimately proceeded to win a good game
against level so now time for a novelty
Bishop g5 now played by my camera um
yeah what should black do against the
smooth we shouldn't forget that this is
the Catalan and White has pretty strong
pressure on that diagonal some some
simple approaches won't work if black
for example it takes on c4 here with the
Queen it looks very normal hair just
take that pawn then why'd will capture
and play it 92 and this is not a very
nice position for black
note that this is just not great and
whites pressure is still very strong
very likely white will just win the c-4
bond back and has and just have pressure
let's say age six and drop back
something like that and why it has a
great position this is the kind of a
dream position of the Catalan opening
you just have to compare the g2 and the
c8 bishop and you know what's going on
so simple recipes um don't cut it here
for black um a lot I'm decided to play
in a dynamic fashion mmm sorry in a
dynamic fashion and went age 6 I think
this is I actually like how he plays but
we'll see that it is not leading to an
easy game white has to take now
otherwise it doesn't make much sense you
don't have a good square if you go back
to AB form there's this kind of thing
happening we by the way should mention
that if you go and be five straight away
White has this point you had that in my
notes but forget to mention it's quite a
funny line now threatens c5 and black
cannot take because of this and Bishop
before yeah so white had to take Bishop
takes Knight a three so why does much
better developed the bishop is serve not
great on c8 but on the other hand he was
some yeah in some way forced to put the
night on that somewhat awkward square
only three okay he could have gone here
but this is far less pointed as the
pressure on d5 has relieved a little bit
19 three years of buzzer is a lot
sharper Bishop d7 and rook to be one
yeah directly taking doesn't help as
this is completely fine for black
group we want to covering that that pawn
down Lucy eight queen bee three there's
still some pressure there a black cannot
take on c4 do to those powerful pieces
yeah Luke t8 was played takes on d5 and
now Queen a fall so we definitely see
some scenario where white wins upon but
black has some active play we should
also note the clock time so the camera
is still quite clearly in its
preparation well on earth is taking time
yeah I mean he had this novelty in on
move 11 and the subsequent moves were
fairly a fairly normal looking Queen a4
and Ruby to covering porn and now be
five played by or not look be one that
was the first move that Nakamura took
took a long long thing with ya and here
now it's it's very tricky for black to
play this position he's a pawn down but
it looks like some compensation my first
instinct when I saw the position was
that black should be okay here because
the night only three looks so awkward
it's on the edge of the board and if you
move at a 2 is under under pressure and
I thought that black should be ok but
it's um it's not an uneasy to prove that
in them in the actual game maybe black
is simply not okay it's very much
possible I looked at a couple of nights
one line that i found interesting was a
six just covering b5 and asking why how
is going to proceed something that
couldn't be three for example is what I
looked at and the idea is that this now
simplifies the position a lot
but even then it's not entirely clear
that black gets full equality I suppose
do you think that check this might be
just a draw no because black attacks
this and all those pawns are weak so it
looks like you should get one back or
maybe get to an opposite colored bishops
endgame but even there it's not a
completely completely straightforward
draw it stuffed the same it's really
tough to say what's clears by the way it
said be4 it's not a great move as night
see for now is better for white black
can take here but after b3 that goes
back and why it goes here he is better
he now has a good night on c4 and he's
got very good centralized pieces Black
now has to worry about this pawn and
probably will take and after this those
two pieces are fantastic yeah so nice
position for white yeah Island decided
to take Bishop takes Bishop c6 and now
he fought that Bishop get some support
and here again I mean isn't shouldn't
black have some chances here it looks a
little bit like it that the a39 is such
a such a bad looking piece but actually
in the game nakamura got very nice
control over this position a 6-h form
Queen B for group B 1 just covering and
he basically says that ok I'm going to
consolidate my position and if I get
that night into the game i'm just a pawn
up a clear porn up it's very tricky for
black to play this and I'm played back
to a 5 trying to get before back into
the game but now before was played by
white and it seems that after this and
this white definitely has a clear
advantage maybe already has it before
but it wasn't so clear to me while here
um if you look at this more closely you
see that black
in bad shape the Queen on a 4 is offside
doesn't do that much and white has ideas
to improve this is for instance a nice
move rupee too if you take the pawn now
after Luke a 485 this is a pretty
terrible set up the Queen cannot move
and white can basically improve now head
will owe our Lucas e7 was tried kingi to
now White has time time to set
everything up perfectly the queen is not
not good on a form and nakamura plated
really nicely now g6 can question this
move as h5m looks uncomfortable but what
should like play it's very very
difficult to grow many advice g5 and
queen d 1 and now very nicely it just
gives away the pawn because the night is
coming over to was it called greener
pastures isn't that nice looking here
looking here fantastic fantastic night
and of course at the move this is
hanging so black is in huge trouble yeah
you cannot take the five do tonight
Jackie seven check try this but now d 6
yeah if black takes and he did that guy
Lauren tix here and goes back to g4 idea
black is completely busted right f6 is a
big threat and something like visually 7
to cover that is answered by this and
again there is no escaping another 20
weaknesses a really great performance by
Nakamura I think very good preparation
if we go back all the way we have to
really give them credit down he had
prepared this up to here yeah and white
white seems to be better here pieces a
porn up and there is no clear-cut way
for black to prove that this
night is really a huge problem for white
maybe it simply isn't and this island
couldn't couldn't prove it in the game
and it's not that he played he has some
very obvious mistakes so a very nice
performance here by Nakamura who with
that win joins the lead here it's quite
funny that we have three year tellement
leaders with plus one Giri mdl and no
Nakamura they all won one game and still
a very very tight race for the first
places um yeah but now I gotta gotta
point now and he's got chances in this
event um yeah I hope you enjoyed the
coverage here of Round four it's a good
one hour long but what can you do even
though I felt it wasn't a very thorough
analysis hope you enjoyed it and I'll be
back for round five just tomorrow thanks
for watching